les rêves sont les graines de l'action nous poupée
qui d'autre se souvient qu'une
course en solitaire autour du monde lui a déjà
envoyé mon formulaire d'inscription il s'est effacé seul sur un
bateau en neuf mois tu es l'ivrogne ou l'
homme eh bien nous devrions prendre un autre verre alors
que nous pouvons exclure la folie, puis-je
souligner que vous n'avez pas de bateau capable d'effectuer
un tel voyage, nous allons en construire un avez-
vous déjà fait quelque chose comme ça avant
que ce soit le point si je peux le faire alors
le gars qui  regarde l'horizon
je mets de l'argent qu'est-ce que tu
mets dans tout le reste je me suis trompé
en pensant que nous étions juste en train de construire un
bateau je ne pensais pas que je devrais vraiment
te regarder partir
c'est ce que les bateaux me promettent
reviendra n'importe quel homme sain d'esprit voudrait se
retirer d'une telle entreprise laissez vos
doutes avec nous ici sur le spectacle
prenez vos rêves pour voir une
grande pression tombe sur l'homme seul sur un
bateau la mer ne montre aucune pitié où  les
leaders 3 000 miles que si je vais sur mes
chances de s  urvival serait 50/50
[Musique]
si je rebrousse chemin, je paye un certain
droit et je ne peux pas rentrer à la maison, alors où
est-il d'autre,
je suis là et si je leur disais mon ouais
[Musique]
cette semaine, la poupée Kroger a  j'ai posté
un discours remarquable qu'est-ce que je fais maintenant
je pensais que je pouvais mieux jouer le jeu
Donald crust voulait être célèbre maintenant
il est sur le point de le faire
nous remettons cela nous avons mis la pression sur
l'homme
nous savons que demain et tous les jours
souvent mes enfants rencontreront encore leur
père et j'aurai encore besoin de mon mari la
vie doit être vécue alors la question
devient que pouvez-vous faire tout cela signifiant
vous